we're gonna do this is sort of a little
quicker than we normally would but if
you could have this working your diagram
diagrams there we're going to pick up
exactly where we left off
hopefully this rings a bell this is a um
better and leta constructed version of
what you saw yesterday on the board and
just to review we were looking at this
3d situation we had the as a tower
wasn't it tower
yeah the tower these three observers and
the three angles of elevation now what
we did was we said okay I don't know any
lengths here I don't know any length and
I'm trying to work out a bearing of some
kind here on the ground and so in order
to get from this 3d situation into a
two-dimensional situation we did all of
this business have a look over the right
hand side you can see I'll just
highlight it for you you can see we
worked out 80 that's probably not very
clear for you let's pick a better color
we picked out 80 BT and CT these are the
lengths on the ground key I see that is
that all right yeah so we got all the
links on the ground using right angle
triangle trig because the tower is
vertical so it always creates a right
angle with the ground and then we saw
that in all these three triangles okay
now I believe the last thing we said was
this down here we were looking at angle
abt do you remember that it was in that
little triangle there you can actually
see it just here abt we're trying to
find this angle in here and we use the
sine rule but where we left off and a
few of you are like I'm getting a
different calculations here where we
left off was these two angles why do I
have two not one
what's the reason yeah recen it can be
the other way around - no just real
quick because we now have the vocabulary
graphs in our brain let me just mute
this for a quick second so remember when
we looked at the graph of sine x we did
it with spaghetti we did it by hand this
is the shape that we got right now the
whole idea is if you know sine of an
angle and I think it's like 0.7 sine of
angle abt is about 0.7 okay what we're
saying is
see this graph remember what it's uh
it's range was where was the lowest two
could go negative one and it was the
highest I could go one very good what
we're saying is hey there's some angle
somewhere on here and when you take the
sine of that you get zero point seven
now we're 0.7 I would place it very
roughly if that's point five I'll put
put seven there that red line right
there that red line represents zero
point seven on the vertical scale now
have a look at the red line and then
have a look at the graph there's an
angle here and an angle here it's like
hey there's two options and the two
options are whatever 44.1 I write down
44.7 or a hundred and thirty five point
three and that should actually make
sense because this mid point here that's
180 degrees isn't it okay so this is why
we have two solutions and that's where
you left up so oh wait hold on why how
can i why am i getting both of them and
not just one is that what your question
okay
no I can just take one if I can use
other information in the diagram to help
me
just see if you remember this when we
were having a look at certain triangles
for instance if I I'm just gonna make up
some numbers they're probably gonna be
wrong but I'm just gonna run with it
anyway suppose we had lengths like this
right and we knew that you got an angle
of let's say that was measured to you
and then you try to find this angle okay
now if you went ahead and you did the
sine rule you got two options there
right you know whatever angle you get
out it has to be bigger than 23 degrees
do you agree with that how do I know
that it has to be bigger than 23
wrastlin very good bigger angles must
match up to or be opposite bigger sides
right so in this case I'm like oh the
sine rule hands me two options but I can
exclude one of them because of other
information in the diagram okay
now let's come back to our working here
because we're going to try and do this
and this is where we left off so you may
like to jot some of this down though
don't worry about drawing down
everything have a look over here in
the bottom left-hand corner I'm trying
to do here what I did over there in that
blue triangle I'm trying to think oh can
I work out from the sides which angle
should be the bigger angle right now if
you go ahead and you pop into your
calculator cut 26 degrees and cut 28
degrees right what you find is that cut
26 degrees is bigger then cut 28 degrees
you can go ahead you can verify it on
your calculator now I don't know how
tall the tower is but it's the same
height on both sides of this inequality
so I can say oh this side here 80 which
is opposite the angle I'm interested in
it's longer than this side beta right
where I have the angle let me just go up
a little bit I have the angle opposite
that right so if I know this side is
bigger than this side then it's angle
should be bigger than the one over here
but that doesn't help can anyone show me
I mean I've written it down here why
doesn't it help to know that the side is
longer met yeah very good I'm like oh
this angle here I can know for sure just
like in my blue example over there it
should be bigger than forty point one
nine but they're both bigger than forty
point one nine so I'm like this is not
enough information I can't sort of
exclude one of the options just from
this alone okay so this is what I did
and like I said don't freak out about
writing this down because there's a lot
there and I'll just pop it up on canvas
for you let me talk you through what
you're looking at
since get this since inside the triangle
I did not have enough information to
work out which I got was I have to look
outside the triangle let me say that
again because a lot of you'll be like
why would you go and do this here's the
reason why
right since this is a triangle here that
I was looking inside and I'm like not
enough information so I have to extend
my view and look outside here's where I
looked angle some of acte this guy here
okay so this is the big triangle and
it's on the ground do you remember that
this forty point one nine we worked that
out earlier okay so using that and
there's a right angle you can work out
this guy here a CT do you see that are
you following the working I just used
the
angle sum of a triangle it's forty nine
point eight one so now I know how big
this is okay and then I wonder I have to
have a thick I've got these two
potential options for abt this is the
one where I was like is it a kid is it
obtuse I don't know yet
so what I did was I thought what happens
if it is acute let's just try it and see
what happens if this is the acute angle
then this angle on the other side it's
on a straight line yeah what's the
relationship between these two angles
they add up to 180 degrees okay so I
said well if that's what this one's
equal to on the other side that's the
supplement okay but then look at what
happens if this is a cute then this is
about 135 I just worked out this is
forty nine point eight one hundred
thirty-five forty nine point eight this
is what they add up to right you can go
ahead you can verify this on your
calculator that's a problem right why is
that a problem it's more than legendary
degrees I'm supposed to be in a triangle
here right the biggest that all three of
these angles can add up to 180 this low
here
it cuts what ninety degrees
cuts this guy here yes so I you know
what I don't even know how big this
angle is I was just looking at these two
that's what this represents and I'm like
I'm already over 180 right does this
make sense I'm like oh oh this is bad
I've broken the diagram okay
so therefore if thinking about the acute
version of the angle breaks things right
you're like no no that can't be that has
to be excluded does this make sense I
tried out the acute version it led to an
impossible diagram so therefore there's
only one conclusion I can make it's not
the acute one it has to be the other one
that shouldn't say for you know I think
that should say two forty four point
seven sorry let me fix that the forty
four point seven is what I tried out but
it didn't work so I said it can't be
forty four point seven it has to be the
other one alright that's the way that
I'm going to resolve the ambiguous case
that's quite tricky it's quite
complicated so why I'm like I can't rush
over this yesterday I had to
you a separate time but once you've got
that it's a matter of them putting all
the angles together in this little
triangle have a look at your diagram
right remember the bearing of B from the
tower the bearing of B from the tower
should be this angle on your diagram 80
bit on the ground okay so you just use
the angle sum of triangle and this is
what you get okay does that make sense
does anyone have any questions on any
part of that cuz I did go through that
fairly quickly any parts that need a bit
of clarification as promised I'll give
you this on campus you don't have to
worry about writing it down but I wanted
you to see the flow of my argument like
resolving this ambiguous case that's a
lot of work and a lot of thinking so
that's why it takes so much space in
fact it's about half of my working is
just dealing with that guy okay